[Musique]
avec les pertes et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand une personne est testée positive
au co vite on reçoit l'information elle
va être contacté m contacter d'abord par
un agent call center qui va identifier
les contacts de la personne deux jours
avant l'apparition des symptômes de
pouvoir et va permettre alors
d'identifier les personnes qui sont à
risque c'est à dire des personnes qui
ont eu des contacts pendant plus de 15
minutes à moins d'un mètre cinquante de
distance avec la personne contaminée
[Musique]
mais dont il fit différentes cas de
figure donc on a les patients qui sont
surpris de notre action et qui dans cet
élan de solidarité qui se met un petit
peu en place nous remercient nous avons
les patients qui ont peur on peur de
divulguer les contacts qu'ils ont peur
de communiquer des informations qui sont
très réticents à notre approche
et puis on a les personnes pour
lesquelles c'est un refus total de
collaborer parce que ils ne se sentent
pas concernés par cette problématique ou
par cet élan là
[Musique]
ce qu'on sait que le système de suivi de
contact par par call center ou par des
agents de terrain reste
restent parcellaires donc on ne peut pas
identifier tous les contacts
problématiques notamment dans les lieux
publics dont les transports en commun
donc on estime qu'une application pour
être vraiment complémentaire au système
actuellement mis en place
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]